here it is right here from
RealClearPolitics battle for the Senate
Real Clear Politics as Republicans
winning 53 seats Democrats 47
Pennsylvania they are saying Oz is going
to win and no question they're saying no
question they're also saying Georgia
Arizona and Nevada
there you go
well you know what's interesting about
that 53 number is it's bad for Democrats
obviously in 2022 but it's awful for
Democrats in 2024 because that map is
very disadvantageous for Democrats in
2024 I mean you look at places like New
Hampshire Pennsylvania West Virginia
Montana Georgia specifically Georgia I
don't know if Georgia is up in 2024
Michigan Wisconsin Minnesota all those
States they're gonna lose more seats in
two years they put up federmanium he's
going to be the guy that breaks the
filibuster Republicans are going to need
a filibuster in into after 2024 if
things break their way in these next two
election Cycles now they may not but you
know this is this is what happens I got
it I really do think there are two
things you can say to somebody let's aim
in 2024 is I don't know if it's possible
do you know do you know how many Senate
seats are up in 2024 it's got to be
third it's a third a third okay so it's
possible that we could see 60 Republican
seats we need what like 63 or something
let's get let's get 66 Republican seats
in the Senate and then just you know run
rough shot just just pass all the bills
ban all the garbage and I think maybe if
you go to people right now and say gas
prices that's number one but the other
thing is while you're talking to people
and you go like gas prices are really
really hurting you right let me show you
this you know I got this thing here
about gas prices and like oops I
accidentally pressed plan this video of
Biden supporting sex changes for
children
I think those two issues are going to
make people jump ship because when CBS
did their panel with the Democrat
Republican and independent what did the
Democrat woman say I've got a bunch of
kids and what's happening in these
schools is bad and I don't like it I was
talking to my mother over the weekend I
went back to her house to hang out for a
few days and Becky I'm gonna put you on
blast I was like you know Biden grabbing
young women and smelling them and like
telling that one girl wait till you're
30 before you get into a serious
relationship like that's scummy dirty
and if I went to the park and did that
to a little kid I probably could throw
in jail she's like he did not so I
showed her the video I showed her the
picture she's like
he shouldn't be touching little kids
he should not be but he's not going to
show you that it's up to us it's and
that's why Elon buying Twitter that's an
October surprise what if one week before
the election Alex Jones
milianopoulos Laura Loomer Donald Trump
they all come back and then and then
they're surfing on that red tsunami
I wonder if that'll have an impact I
mean these are loud voices I think I
mean there's a reason they were censored
there's a reason you know not just
right-wingers but also people on the
left a lot of anti-establishment types
were censored because they're not
censored because they were wrong they're
censored because they were a threat
towards the current narrative towards
the current agenda and they needed to
silence those voices in order to make
sure that their agenda their narrative
could go through it without even
question or without even being
questioned without being stopped at all
and I think this is why we had so much
lunacy during the last two and three
years because no one could have
challenged it you challenged it you got
banned right away this is again why I
see Twitter as a net positive
possibly moving forward well you know
it's interesting you talk about that
focus group right and people saying this
this stuff that that's going on in
schools well look it's been out there
for a long time now but it's just it
could never get traction on social media
could never get Traction in the
mainstream media because they didn't
want to talk about it they didn't want
to offend the far left that thought this
was all great but where it all starts to
come out is when you've got you know
little Johnny with his Chromebooks
sitting home from school and then Mom
and Dad also sitting home from school
working and they were like what we never
heard about this and then people start
digging in and then you start activating
all these people and you cannot you
cannot unring that Bell right now and so
that is that is an exact point when you
have gas prices where they are inflation
where it is you know threat of war with
Russia over Ukraine and he's talking to
you know a guy that's pretending to be a
girl in the white house I mean come on
you know I've watched that and says that
person is Faking It
Dylan Mulvaney is intentionally trying
to insult trans people and women and
there's nothing anyone can say to
convince me otherwise Blair white said
no I know people who know him and and
you know Dylan is actually trans and I'm
like there's no like
that's I just don't buy it I think I
think Dylan Mulvaney's whole bit and
I've talked we've talked about a couple
times is intentionally trying to insult
trans people it's it's it's you look at
these videos and you're like that is
look at videos of your average trans
person that is not what Dylan Mulvaney
is doing like Blair white is a is an
example of a conservative I think the
player's conservative I assume Trump's
supporting and then you look at Contra
points the two examples left and right
they do not act like that this Dylan
Mulvaney goes to the White House and
says extremely offensive things come on
like Dylan Mulvaney made a video about
how he's he's got a bulge and everyone
was staring at it like that I'm telling
you man this person is trying to make
trans people to insult trans people and
and there and and Dylan's probably
laughing every time he puts a video out
because conservatives are watching it
saying look how crazy they are and the
left is being like we we better protect
it it's like that that teacher you saw
the high school teacher with the big
fake tits some people are suggesting
that was a troll I saw that maybe it was
a troll I'm like I wouldn't be surprised
oh I mean look I gotta be honest I mean
maybe Society is collapsing people are
losing their minds but I really think
when you look at the there are a lot of
people who are trans that are not
prominent and you might not even notice
and they've been around for a long time
then you look at Dylan and everyone
assumes that's what trans is I'm like
not Dylan is just intentionally it's a
character it's a caricature it's a
mockery it's a it's a it's akin to a
Minstrel show and there's nothing anyone
can anyone can say to convince me
otherwise because
Blair White's not walking around talking
about Barbie pouches like what does that
even word hiking heels dude she doesn't
make her personality about her gender
you know it's a show Dylan is doing a
show it's fake fake fake anyway look
look I gotta I gotta ask you this
question uh-oh look at this map what am
I pointing to right there what is that
New Hampshire what what color is that uh
I don't know I might be colorblind I
can't I can't really what color is that
Luke what is that what color is New
Hampshire Ian correct who's the governor
of New Hampshire it's blue it's blue New
Hampshire how is New Hampshire voting a
Democrat senator in Bernie Sanders no
he's Vermont he's Vermont I don't know
and he's independent anyway who runs
that I guess I don't know much about
that race that's happening in the Senate
there but I do know the governor over
there sununu now here we have it oh
Governor red what happened oh yeah I'm
sure I don't understand how you get a
red governor and a blue it's the free
state project
a lot of uh they call them [ __ ] a
lot of people moving up from
Massachusetts and uh changing the
landscape there but that's right I don't
think it matters what political party
are you affiliate with personally I want
good people I don't care what label you
slap on your shirt hey I'm still a big
fan of the free state project I think
they're doing incredible work and I
think a lot of them especially with the
homeschooling Network down there is
doing incredible stuff that I think
should be replicated and cop copied
everywhere else their meetups their
Community is awesome going strong and
doing really really incredible things
you know so they're not affiliated red
or blue Republican well they're they're
in the local government there's a lot of
uh you know free Staters in uh the the
state representative uh local
governments there that are implementing
local laws local jurisdictions making
sure that you could actually get raw
milk uh ice cream that was one of the
big hurdles making sure that you could
carry your firearm when you're on an ATV
and there's a lot of other legal battles
especially when it comes to taxes and
tax credits especially from
homeschooling that they did have very
significant victories on by coming
together and working together on those
issues what was the no gun on an ATV
problem they were New Hampshire had some
weird law where you couldn't have a gun
on a snowmobile or ATV and they of
course repealed it with work of the free
state project in local government see
this is what's what's what's brutal is
them I pulled up 270 to win state house
elections map only 31 States
so
Senate and and uh representative State
legislatures it's only 31 States going
Republican New Hampshire of course has
read free state project Maine and
Minnesota are considered toss-ups so
we'll see but even then it's only 33. we
need a handful more man what do you need
like 30 37 or something for a Convention
of states
yeah I think it was uh who was it that
we were talking about oh it was uh Doug
mastriano I mentioned hey Convention of
States then we can fix everything he's
like be careful with that because they
can use that against you too people can
call Convention of states and like
change laws they can't right you still
need to have done right so we we talked
to the Convention of States guys they
were on the show and they said it's not
what happens the convention of States
allows a convention to occur where they
make proposals and then they have to
vote on the changes to the Constitution
they don't just do it does it go to this
it doesn't go to the Senate bypasses the
Senate it's the states only so the state
so it would have to be the Republicans
voting and then my question is if the
Republicans convene a Convention of
states is it going to be Republicans
Banning 2A or are they going to be like
we reaffirm and re you know rein you
know restate the all I mean like the NFA
outright violates the Constitution
we just as a society just allow these
things to happen the funny thing is most
I I should say the problem is most
people don't care about their rights
being eroded
that's it
like like everyone's being spied on
nobody cares
it's that subtlety that people don't
it's when you don't perceive it you know
a little bit like erosion slow erosion
uh is unnoticeable almost but when a big
huge chunk of land breaks off that type
of erosion everyone freaks out about
well that that's one of the points I
brought up earlier with like local local
issues right most people are not tuned
into what's going on locally they'll
tune into the national stuff because
it's on television all the time right
you need to turn on Fox or CNN or
whatever Network you want to watch and
they're going to be covering the Senate
they're going to be covering the house
they're going to be covering the
presidentials but maybe you have 10 of
people on on the right and 10 of the
people on the left in these local
elections that actually care and then
they show up to the extent they do in
these low turnout local elections and
they're just guessing they don't know
anything about these people because
they're not paying attention they're
busy with soccer practice they're busy
with school they're busy with their
day-to-day life but that's where it all
starts right all these people that are
you know running for these big offices
now all get their start at the school
board the county boards all these local
offices and they get in there and they
start moving on up and if people don't
pay attention to what's going on locally
that's why we're in the problems we're
now what kind of commitment is it to be
local official
I mean it's it's low paid uh like if
you're a school board member you get
paid twenty thousand dollars a year so
you're not doing it for the money you
may be doing it because you know you're
an activist and you want your policies
in place or more likely than not you
you're a political climber and this is
your first step to the next step so you
right off the bat you've got to start
you know paying the favors that you owe
and making sure that you're appeasing
your base and and playing politics at
the local level
do they convene weekly monthly is it
every day how often does a school board
member for instance uh every two weeks
you do like what like six hours they do
they do like a yeah about a six hour
public meeting and then they have
committee meetings which are often you
know they could be virtual they could be
in person it is a lot of work for them
to do it
um so you know when you have people
doing it it's I kind of break it down as
to you've got the true activists you got
the political climbers you've got the
people that are actually went there
because they believe in in public
service and then you got the people that
believe in public service but have been
so beaten down by the first two that
they're just you know checking in and
checking out
and that's what local government looks
like so should we pay a million bucks
will that make sure that the people are
there for the paycheck and not for the
activism
I don't know I don't think that's a real
solution I just think that it's always
going to be activists the problem is
where are our activists who want to be
there yeah I'm doing the show personally
like you're doing a show what are you
doing here and maybe you should be out
I'm thinking um but I do think shows
like this are massively influential
because you can get a lot of people to
vote the way you want them to vote when
10 000 people or 100 000 people hear
your voice although imagine you know 10
years from now Ian's governor of West
Virginia
and we're like remember when he was on
the show and then he decided you know he
got to do something and now he's the
governor and
constitutional carries been enshrined in
the federal level Ian's running for
president you know what I don't like
about governorship right now is that
they can decide for their state
if it's abortions legal or not one
person
chosen by the government no the governor
who decides the state legislature so how
many people is that depends on the state
in some states it's 50 some states it's
300. is the governor involved in that so
it depends on the state some some yes
some know uh in some states the way
it'll work is the state house will
propose a bill they'll vote on it if it
passes it goes to the state senate who
will vote on it if it passes it goes to
the governor Governor's deck and desk
and he can say veto or a a sign veto but
not in every state the governor doesn't
have veto power does Governor veto I
don't know about every single state I
think like Nebraska is an assembly
structure and some states have like a
senate I don't know it depends on the
state man but they basically function
like similarly to the to the to the
federal government I get edgy over
top-down Authority but what do you think
about governance right now do you think
it's like do you like the way it's set
up
uh yeah I mean it does depend on the
state but do I governance generally
locally nationally
what are we talking Statewide governance
with a governor at the top president at
the top of the national government that
kind of that kind of yeah I think you
need it I mean I think you need you know
it's it's federalism right if if you
have too powerful of a state legislature
you're dealing with the same issues you
would have if you didn't have that check
and balance at the national level
checking Congress right if you don't
have that at the state level there's a
lot of things that get done at the state
level that don't get done at the federal
level the federal government will try
and get those done but most of the
consequential stuff that affects your
day-to-day life happens at the state
level so if you're flipping every you
know every which way and you don't have
those checks and balances in the state
government as well your lives going to
be impacted so we had Ammon Bundy on
last week and he was saying that if he
becomes Governor he's going to make
abortion illegal basically and that's
just a vague you know a chance saying
he's a policy plan and he's going to
advocate for it and then hopefully get
to sign it advocate for it I get you
advocate for it to this to the
legislature then they get to decide what
to do with it okay saying if you get
this to my desk I will sign it you think
you'll ever run for State office no any
kind of office you have any no
aspirations right now never definitely
not where are you going to run first I
will say right now there will never be a
circumstance where I will ever run for
public office I don't know if I can help
people with public I mean I bet I could
I think what is the job is a lot of
listening
like you go in and there's 50 other
people that want to talk so you just
wait and listen to everybody the power
is going to go to your head you're going
to do mandatory DMT trips for everybody
I could see it now but I mean if you do
breathing to incite the DMT Rush yeah
dude holotropic breathing that's one way
of doing it
every single person who turns 18 has to
go to a next go go in for Extended State
DMT it's like a three-day thing where
they put you on a on a bed with the IV
drip for DMT and then a screen comes out
of the floor and it's Ian's face and
he's like you can do this I don't want
to do this man you have to do this
the Aztecs did that before obsidian
ritual cutting hearts out and stuff the
resistance the resistance breaks into
Ian's Palace chamber and they're like
it's over Crossland we're putting an end
to and then he hits a button and it
sprays dmtl on their faces and they're
like ah Luke do you have aspirations to
run for office I I I hate politicians I
don't want to hate myself that much and
no hell no
um I just I just don't see it I I see
more positive change being done by by by
media rather than being in a political
office yup culture
culture is very right we've had governor
candidates come on the show but I've
never been to their Governor's Mansion I
mean I'd go there look around take some
people well there's candidates they
don't have Mansions okay who's more
influential you know uh Tucker Carlson
or like your your local Congressman yeah
I mean that's that's a question that I
think is worth asking Tucker for sure
Tucker I mean it depends celebrity is
celebrity AO sees a celebrity she's
really like fallen out of the Limelight
a little bit the Democrats have really
lost any
they haven't got anybody like you know
we said AOC the other day is a-lister
but like she's really not getting the
press these days no no no yeah the
squad's gone but the Republicans keep
getting it see this is the fault of the
Democrats who chase after the the
far-right they say they made it so that
Lauren bobert MTG Trump DeSantis are the
news and now nobody cares about their
candidates so sorry guys you think
you'll ever run for office Ian no I mean
I I agree with that I think that I mean
first of all if you run for office to be
really good really good you need to say
this is what I stand for and I am not
going to let the pressure get to me
where you start you know compromising on
your views and and then you start you
know you just lose who you are while
you're running for office and it happens
to a lot of people it doesn't happen to
everybody but you see it happen and I
see it happen all over the place where
you're like oh well that person said
that because he was in a crowd of people
that that think that and doesn't want to
lose that Vote or she doesn't want to
lose that vote and then you just you
know it's it's sort of a natural
reaction I think for people and there
are other ways to to sort of influence
policy to influence you know culture
um Beyond just running for political Ops
I think you have to have that that
um the right characteristic right stuff
to run for office I've never thought
that I would be that person it happened
to AOC she was talking about how big and
bad the military industrial complex was
now she's one of their biggest
supporters and funders right these
people are pathological Liars this is
why I I hate election season they're
lying through their teeth they're full
of crap on almost every single issue and
I don't care if you're a Democrat or
Republican there's very few people that
are able to actually impress me and talk
about the real legitimate issues that
actually matter instead of just giving
me generalized platitudes that don't
amount to jack-ish and only amount to
them trying to get you to support them
and whenever you're a human being that
puts your power your energy when
whenever you put someone else above
yourself you're committing an act that
that shouldn't be be respected you
shouldn't be a simp for politicians you
should believe in yourself you should
Empower yourself and at the end of the
day one person who's going to fix all
your problems it's not going to be that
politician it's going to be you when you
decide you had enough of the bull crap
and you're going to make changes and
decisions in your life that actually
benefit you instead of giving up all of
your power to Mr douchebag or Mr turd
sandwich but it wasn't it just so much
easier just to not think about it Lou no
just give up yeah when when you see the
atrocities when you see so many human
beings being poisoned being screwed over
being absolutely robbed of their wealth
robbed of their Futures no it's it's not
easy because the amount of hurt that
politicians are putting on the American
people doesn't amount to any form of
laziness or convenience that just by
voting them in but I wonder if that's
just part of the system the structure of
the system that people have because
you're saying like every almost every
politician becomes some sort of
is that I wonder if it's all of them
either that's a problem with Humanity
which may be but I don't I want to think
better than that that it's a problem
with the way the system's set up that
people all of a sudden they get some
votes and now they're they have more
power than you maybe it should be that
they have ability to alter what are you
going to say yeah so I liken it to this
right so you've got your your network uh
shows right your your sort of mass uh
consumption sitcoms and they're on
broadcast right and they do well and a
lot of politicians are like that but
then you have your really good shows
smart shows that are still able to
achieve success you know it could be on
HBO could be on any of these other
platforms so you still do have that but
you have to really be able to balance
you know popular appeal but staying true
to your ideals right that's that's what
makes a not just a good politician but a
good elected official we do have a lot
of these you know generic broadcast
network shows that are bound on
television you see the promos for them
when you're watching the NFL over and
over again for 20 years that does make
up a lot of the political class you
think there are elected officials that
aren't politicians
I think they're elected officials that
will engage in being a politician to get
to office and then actually do the job
that's required of them but being a
politician and being a you know a
candidate I mean you've got to make
phone calls and ask people for money
that is the worst thing in the world I
don't know how anybody ever does that
I've got a pack out and loud and fight
for schools I used to have to I called
some people last summer to try and raise
money for you know our recall efforts it
was horrible you know you're like yeah
can you give me uh what can you can you
do well I'll give you 200 that's oh
that's awesome thanks for like what did
you only ask for 200 yeah I can't ask
for more that sounds horrible I don't
know I know but I used to do non-profit
fundraising and I would always this is
what the average person comes in so I'm
doing this canvas thing they'd be like
can you give
five bucks a month and they'd be like
okay and they'd be like okay and then
I'd be like why don't you ask for 100. I
can't ask for a hundred dollars are you
kidding let me show you it's done I walk
up to a guy and I'm like we want you to
sign up and I've I've got like a trainee
and they're like What's it gonna cost
I'm like I'd like you to give me a
thousand dollars per month and then the
guy just laughed like are you kidding
and I was like oh no I want you to give
me a thousand dollars per month
otherwise who else is going to help us
stop deforestation and the guy goes oh I
can't give you a thousand dollars I'm
like how about a hundred bucks and he
goes I can do a hundred and I'm like
you get what you ask for that's that's
the thing but I get it man fundraising
is brutal so I think that's another
reason I wouldn't want to be I would do
it like via internet video you know but
I don't even know if it violates
YouTube's terms of service but of course
you could have your own social network
and work off minds and things like that
yeah that's I I don't understand that
politicians should just be putting out
broad spectrum videos where they're like
I need you guys to donate today here's
why and then just do like a 10 Minute
Podcast YouTube video social media put
on all the platforms that's way more
effective than picking up the phone and
calling random people
but then they they use the pick up the
phone system to be like well that means
I need to hire 10 people which means I
need to raise this amount of money
because you you don't need money to be a
YouTube Star I did I when I started I
had nothing I had a 60 30 webcam and a
15 microphone you know how you win these
days it's like think about anything
they're doing they're going door to door
it's like just film everything and post
videos making phone calls buying
commercials a commercial is less
effective than you making your own video
that goes viral for whatever reason
so you know when Bloomberg was running
he put half a billion dollars or
whatever into this race and all these
YouTubers started getting tons of money
and they're like that's just I guess
when you're a really unpopular guy with
really horrifying ideas you have to pay
for it but if you're a politician you
want to run you've got good ideas you
can just do all earned press make make
YouTube videos you don't need to spend a
single dime on it Donald Trump
his it was all earned press he spent
very little money relative to uh to
Hillary and other candidates because
they just kept talking about him on the
TV ain't how to do it
but that wasn't even him making his own
YouTube videos nowadays you could just
make your own YouTube show and be like
hey I'm running and give me money
yeah I mean think about this people are
members at timcast.com so that we can
make more shows and we're not even
running for office
so you know people are willing to sign
up to help to contribute you just gotta
be
better at it I guess it's always driven
me nuts how like the great politicians
are the people that don't want to do it
they're like I don't want that power I
don't want that it's not right but then
you're like but you have to because
you're the right guy like you're the one
that will put it down when you're done
with it
but no one's gonna force you to do it so
unless you take the reins and make
yourself go so Ian
I mean to do politics you would have to
you're up against the global and then
you take the military into account and
it's like oh my god do I want to be in
charge of who lives and dies I mean I'd
rather me than somebody else but I want
everyone to imagine Ian sitting at the
Oval Office desk justifying why they had
a drone bomb that Pakistani Village
that's so gross
no but you like think about the kind of
person you could imagine saying
something like that but then you have
real threats where like there's an
invasion force it hasn't happened really
in our in our modern history to the
United States we don't have any yeah we
do haven't had a real invasive threat
what do you mean the United States we
yeah several years people are Marching
In in the tens of thousands with their
Flags I would have sent the National
Guard out night too yeah that's what
Carrie lake has been saying National
Guard man Carrie lake has been calling
for the National Guard to go down and
stop The Invasion the Border dude and
the cartels now you want to talk about
an enemy you do not well I don't want to
make enemies with cartels who are on our
but we've got like a drug uh what do
they call it a a narco terrorist State
on our Southern border like The Mexican
government is the cartel essentially and
they're it's like the cartel is a form
of government that operates but they're
intergovernmental I mean you've got
cartel operating even up in Maryland and
you know up in that is freaking yes
that's true haven't you ever watched
breaking bad dude has it always just
been military Authority since the
beginning I don't remember looking at
history I don't know of a time when it
wasn't military Authority first and then
everything else well yeah we're in a
bubble
I mean it's a crazy thing dude you just
because I I got to say it I've been
reading about the Civil War and
there was no Lincoln suspends habeas
corpus from DC up to Philly up up to
Pennsylvania basically because Maryland
was a slave state so they're just
randomly arresting people this is why
the the four states in 1861 in May
seceded because Abraham Lincoln was like
I'm not gonna allow these seven states
to secede we're gonna use Force then
four other states Tennessee North
Carolina Arkansas Virginia we're all
like yo we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
Stand By and let you do that it was
brutal but it was war
you know what do you do when War when
War breaks out
everything else is is just
words on paper you know you you can come
out and be like I've got a
constitutional right to this that or
otherwise and they're going to be like
yeah well we're being invaded by you
know China or whatever so I don't care
like we in the the United States
interned Japanese people like that is
certainly not constitutional didn't
matter
Wars War yeah did it anyway winning
so if it really does break down and get
crazy people don't understand how crazy
can really get everybody tries to base
what they think is happening in this
country off of what's already happening
right now what happened in the past but
you know what man what people really
don't get
every single War there's a there's a
there's a this technology has advanced
in weapons and so when the next War
breaks out people are taken by surprise
at the weapons that are being used so
just consider this
you have the invention of rifled muskets
and even breach loading uh rifles in the
Civil War and that that increased
accuracy of the rifles by like 400 for
percent so now bayonet charges don't
work and and many groups tried that
imagine where we go now imagine if a war
actually broke out what do you think
we're going to see it's not just going
to be AR-15s there's going to be weird
things they're going to be drones
there's going to be a DJI drone and it's
going to be carrying a a small payload
and P and it's going to fly up and then
zoom straight at you and explode there's
going to be people with microwave
cannons so like active denial systems it
shoots microwaves at people so it makes
them feel like they're on fire laser
weapons lrads tiny tiny drone bullets
that are going to be controlled and just
fly into someone's head and blow up
that's right thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there